ladies and gentlemen to present the  award for the best performance by an  actress in a supporting role a veteran  of just about every medium that there is  entertainment in last year's Academy  Award winner Ed Begley  I'm not allowed to ad-lib last year but  I'm here to present the award for the  best performance by an actress in a  supporting role the nominees are  lilius Scala in lilies of the field for  her portrayal of the strong will  Dame Edith Evan in Tom Jones for her  portrayal of the Squires sister and his  Western  Diane Cilento in Tom Jones for her  portrayal of the flirting country wench  Joyce Redman in Tom Joel for her  portrayal of a might have been mother  Noblet brother / the winner is  Margaret brother her  accepting for Margaret Rutherford Peter  Ustinov  may I on behalf of a most distinguished  most deserving and most funny friends  say thank you very much indeed